last time you and i talked uh we were
talking about motorcycles you still ride
a motorcycle
or i know you had a whole period of your
life yeah in your youth where you
crisscross the country on a motorcycle
and i'm curious is that still a part of
your life at all have you given it up
completely
i tell you i used to have a harley and
uh
traveled the country for two years on a
motorcycle back in the 70s and i had a
harley for years
now i've got a got a scooter
yeah and it's called a fat scooter
and i crisscross ventura boulevard
nothing scares me man i'm gone
look out yeah and you keep diaries you
keep like your road diaries yeah
crossing ventura boulevard
a bug splattered on my eyeglasses
keep that one that'll go in the memoir
yeah that's very nice
yeah you talked about those days and how
you would
you would ride your motorcycles back in
the 70s you would ride your motorcycle
you would
camp out you'd go to sleep in the dark
not even knowing half the time where you
were bedding down for the night
you'd just lay down someplace and then
in the daytime you'd realize
where you were yes so my brother and i
were together and we were in our early
20s and we took off from california and
i had 175 dollars in my pocket so
that doesn't that doesn't last that long
but
in the 70s uh it wasn't a litigious
society it didn't it wasn't overburdened
by paperwork so you can get a job
anywhere anytime
you walk into a restaurant that's super
busy and go look
do you want me to bust tables yeah would
you here's 20 bucks
i'll bust for a couple hours i get fed
and then i'm
done and it's like we did that all the
time uh it was
it's kind of nice and then we're pulling
into a city and basically
we had a rule if you're in a city and
it's the week day
then you would look for a church or a
synagogue or someplace and you
go drive in the back and usually they
have a little square of grass you can
throw your sleeping bag down and they
didn't really care
if you if it's a weekend you look for a
school and so we did that a lot
sometimes you can't find anything at
night and we saw this park
and there's a fence and these beautiful
trees and all this grass over there so
we
threw our sleeping bags over climbed the
fence went out
into the grass away from the trees that
we didn't want anything falling on us
and we went to bed and the next morning
we were like
oh it's like just sun is starting to
come up we're starting to
come come awake and
i look over and there's a golf ball
about
and then there's another golf ball there
no
sorry we were one of the hazards
so you're in a driving range essentially
we're on a golf course
it's insane and then one time we did the
same thing
we were so tired that we we thought we
saw a park
we climbed a fence against got to a
grassy area
and then we're putting things down and i
realized
oh i can put my things against this
stone
this headstone oh we were on a cemetery
right but we were so tired we thought
you know what the hell with it
you have to be pretty tired to say ah
what are they gonna bother us
yeah no